[SPEAKER_01]: After milking the mail, fifth of Whale's son, 2 a.m. in the morning, Jude has just expressed the poison glands of the mail you tie.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're sick, man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Snap his teeth off.
[SPEAKER_01]: He hands the vial to Paul Ribeiro, basically saying, Knock yourself out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then I take like a pair of like little, you know, pliers or something like that out of, off the, well there's not a table.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got those in my belt.
[SPEAKER_03]: Took them off the rack before I went into the room.
[SPEAKER_03]: And without even asking the guy anything at all, I snap off both of his things.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, snap or do you want to just pull them out?
[SPEAKER_02]: Pull.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's disturbing, to say the least.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude, however, doesn't seem to be that disturbed by it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even the jailer is a little queasy at what Jude does.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it's because Jude is...
[SPEAKER_01]: Not incredibly strong, not un-strong, but truthfully, not skilled, necessarily, in this.
[SPEAKER_01]: He knows what he's doing, but it's not like he does this every day.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he keeps muttering to himself during the process, going, no, no, this is better.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I need to twist.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I forgot about that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, the first one takes around two minutes to pull out.
[SPEAKER_01]: More than once, Jude has to remind the guard what his duty is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, hold him!
[SPEAKER_01]: Hold him!
[SPEAKER_01]: The other guy just basically struggles and twists until Jude is able to get a good hold on it and yank the tooth free.
[SPEAKER_01]: The next one comes faster.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude understanding now just how much force he has to apply without snapping the tooth and to pull it out.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the guard, wanting to get through with this,
[SPEAKER_01]: Being more steady and strengthful in what he's doing to keep the man contained.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're getting better.
[SPEAKER_01]: So are you, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three minutes later, the guy is sitting there, and he doesn't seem to be any more cowed than he was before.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hissing at you, even though blood is dripping down the front of the face.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got some pain tolerance, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get me that torch.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's gonna say, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, let's see how this works.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hold his hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: I burn his hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unnecessary, I told you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two times now.
[SPEAKER_00]: What did you tell me as I hold the torch?
[SPEAKER_00]: Unnecessary torch.
[SPEAKER_00]: We could use it for more sustainable profits.
[SPEAKER_00]: Inventionary products.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you want to take parts of it, I got those two fangs that I just threw over in the corner.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm sure you might actually be able to do something with them.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe grind them up?
[SPEAKER_03]: Put them in something?
[SPEAKER_00]: Join me and I'll give you 20% less labor than all the other future convicts.
[SPEAKER_03]: We will make the future.
[SPEAKER_03]: Leslie, Leslie, if you need to step out, you can step out now, Leslie.
[SPEAKER_03]: But you just need to relax.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, how do you deal with the burning?
[SPEAKER_01]: He deals with the pain very well, but you can tell that it is affecting him.
[SPEAKER_02]: If he's turning into a snake, what do snakes hate?
[SPEAKER_02]: They hate the cold.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, that'll just slow his ass down and make him, like, you know, sluggish.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know that they hate the cold.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, they do.
[SPEAKER_03]: They live in the... You know what it is?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, but they go out to get warm, and then when it's too warm, they go into the shade.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I mean...
[SPEAKER_03]: They go into the shade, because when it gets too hot.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because they can't regulate, so they have to regulate with the weather.
[SPEAKER_02]: Should we just get a fire going under this chair?
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on, Dave.
[SPEAKER_03]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_01]: We talked about these people.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not going to be tortured.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't have human feelings anymore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, Jude and Paul are engaging in kind of a worthless situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're experimenting, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're trying to figure out what they can do to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, you know
[SPEAKER_01]: This direction is not gonna do anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, we were thinking drugs, and we were thinking, uh, alcohol.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, we'll shove a funnel down this guy's throat and make him, like, you know, take a bunch of red-eye.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: Waterboard.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or palace hooch.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, better than hooch, obviously.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to do, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you have a preference?
[SPEAKER_03]: For what?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, for what we do next.
[SPEAKER_03]: He is experiencing pain with a burning hand, so let's just say, why don't we just give him some drugs in?
[SPEAKER_03]: So if we're going to take drugs...
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I don't have anything like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sure I can get some.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know about drugs that make the pain worse.
[SPEAKER_03]: Usually people take drugs because it makes them feel better.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or numb makes them feel numb.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you have to be a little bit careful because if you numb something...
[SPEAKER_01]: The only drug I'll take is that one's throat.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he looks at Jude.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: That is not a good insult.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, it's not an insult.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's just being pissed.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll drink his blood and tell you what you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you think that's not an insult?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think he's trying to shoot a shot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Was that a shot?
[SPEAKER_03]: He's just pissed because I turned into a snake and I said, fuck that.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I still got the snake eyes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_03]: What is with you?
[SPEAKER_03]: You're...
[SPEAKER_03]: These fuckers.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why do you think I responded so about the mask?
[SPEAKER_03]: Why not like anything like a snake?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you serious?
[SPEAKER_02]: You just couldn't do anything better.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why not a giant eagle?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or like...
[SPEAKER_02]: They're...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I guess you didn't do a deer.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's part of the whole Sewell Brotherhood thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: They worship this shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is part of their... You don't know anything else.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, why don't you tell me?
[SPEAKER_03]: What is the whole snake thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Why the snake motif?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's Samyar Combs.
[SPEAKER_01]: In this form, we can hear it better.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, so we can hear someone better.
[SPEAKER_03]: Remember that thing that I said that it was called?
[SPEAKER_03]: The Samyar?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's Samyar.
[SPEAKER_02]: The poison.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, told you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fangs.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll bet you they distill it somehow with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's great.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so Samyar, do I know anything about Samyar?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I make a religious check?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, make a history check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if I've got...
[SPEAKER_03]: Leslie?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep, I do have history, so I have a plus eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thirteen?
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus eight?
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty-one?
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, actually, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yooka.
[SPEAKER_01]: Insigniar is supposedly an ancient dragon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Scaled one?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, an ancient black dragon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll your dice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so... You guys are... Do I know the connection between the ancient Sewell?
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nsemiar is an ancient black dragon of legend that is associated with the alchemical process of the Negrado.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's called the
[SPEAKER_01]: Break down the destruction or dissolution of matter.
[SPEAKER_01]: The boiling.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's like whenever you have like a chemical thing you're about to start up, what you do is you boil it, you burn it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's called cooking, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And Samiar is the god of cooking.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys made him into a snake and you couldn't do the one thing in a snake.
[SPEAKER_03]: That sucks.
[SPEAKER_03]: You don't understand that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was like raiding their temple.
[SPEAKER_03]: It wasn't exactly like they wanted to turn into the scarlet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to say that to them?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Scarlet Brotherhood isn't even like impressive.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of just like... Really?
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys can't do any better?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, we're snakes.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't correct him.
[SPEAKER_03]: I let him roll with that.
[SPEAKER_03]: He wants to mock him.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't really care.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can go with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just saying.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you know the Samyar thing?
[SPEAKER_03]: Like, great.
[SPEAKER_03]: But you guys are celebrating Samyar's form because you look a little bit more like you're gonna be a cobra.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that like a thing?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or is it just anything?
[SPEAKER_03]: All reptilians worship the dragon.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so it is a scaled one thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are they all like the same snake?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, probably not.
[SPEAKER_02]: That sucks.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get a coral snake.
[SPEAKER_03]: I look over out of the girl.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got polymorphed.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's different, okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: They're doing like a voluntary transformation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Imagine getting turned into a garden snake.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, they're doing a fault.
[SPEAKER_03]: And, first of all, we have more problems because, like, these guys were walking around plain as day, as you said.
[SPEAKER_03]: You said they were being stupid.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think they were being stupid.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, they weren't.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it was nighttime.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, but I don't think that they give a shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think that basically there's a lot of them or their agents that probably aren't snakes, to be fair, walking around in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, like, who hired you?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that's been my problem.
[SPEAKER_03]: Whoever hired you was like...
[SPEAKER_02]: Playing that horrible.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, you guys were super easy to follow.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, they just wanted him dead.
[SPEAKER_03]: They got what they wanted.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, well, their exit strategy was not suffice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey, does this guy have a fork, Tom?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
Ooh.
[SPEAKER_02]: I could split his tongue.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know, but I'd still like to be able to listen to him.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a little hard with his R's.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah, you would know.
[SPEAKER_01]: You would know.
[SPEAKER_01]: So one thing you should know, human.
[SPEAKER_01]: This elf, susceptible to the gift as well, he hears the dragon's call.
[SPEAKER_01]: Really?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, in time... Maybe.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you mean maybe?
[SPEAKER_01]: In time, he will fall and succumb himself to the gift.
[SPEAKER_01]: Count on it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess just keep a close eye on me.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's all he's trying to say.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you think someone could do this?
[SPEAKER_01]: And not be affected by it at all?
[SPEAKER_01]: When he was pulling my teeth from my head, I looked into his eyes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they're colder than any of the others I've seen.
[SPEAKER_01]: And believe me, I run with a very cold
[SPEAKER_01]: Look at his eyes, human.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's something there much deeper.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then let's on.
[SPEAKER_00]: You done?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do an end check.
[SPEAKER_00]: My dice has always sucked.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it still sucked.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've had eleven three times.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eleven's not bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get to add your intelligence.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fifteen solid.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's better than roll with a one or a two.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what have you, elf, transformed?
[SPEAKER_01]: When or what?
[SPEAKER_01]: How do you feel?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you hear in the night when the dragon comes calling to you?
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, I kind of don't really think about
[SPEAKER_03]: I usually just meditate so that I can cram more spells so I can kick more ass.
[SPEAKER_01]: Human gods do not exist.
[SPEAKER_01]: However...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, buddy.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, dragons are gods among us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I mean, I'd say they exist, but I don't know that I'd say that they're gods.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're more like magical creatures.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you hear a dragon?
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you ever seen a red devil dragon with thorns and you call that a god?
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: In a book.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm actually thinking, have I been in the dragon?
[SPEAKER_03]: And he busts out in the book and I'm all...
[SPEAKER_02]: The less is all, but I was inside of the book, too.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know the book.
[SPEAKER_02]: I live with the book.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am the book.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't read the book.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dad's like, I don't read the book.
[SPEAKER_02]: The book reads me.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, yeah, I mean, look, I'm not worried.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't really hear anything yet, but if I start talking about, like, you know, talking to myself or something...
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, they'll just kill you probably, but anyways, um...
[SPEAKER_03]: So what we need to do is we need to figure out, he can tolerate a lot of pain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ask yourself this, Princely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why would an elf be away from his own people?
[SPEAKER_01]: Why would he live among humans?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's kind of a bum.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why would you have a bum in your house?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I...
[SPEAKER_02]: I apparently will let anyone in these days.
[SPEAKER_03]: He didn't get to choose.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got assigned to him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you were pretty cheap.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, let's go back to torturing unless you got something else.
[SPEAKER_03]: You got something else that you can figure out?
[SPEAKER_02]: A cheap slave.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, what?
[SPEAKER_02]: You got something else you can figure out?
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me go make a contraption.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys can torture him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, contraption?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not like a contraption.
[SPEAKER_03]: By the way, I need a guard.
[SPEAKER_03]: I look at one of the guards.
[SPEAKER_03]: You guys got a spoon?
[SPEAKER_03]: I need a spoon.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like, you know, from porridge or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: Metal, not wood.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna get some metal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hammers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nails.
[SPEAKER_00]: Chemicals.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do need a spin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Guard brings you a spin.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, I can take out another sample thing and I pop out an eye.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude goes to work and pulls the guy's eye out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he doesn't scream, but he hisses during the entire process.
[SPEAKER_03]: Besides with that tongue, that might be good for chemical agents, too.
[SPEAKER_03]: That tongue.
[SPEAKER_03]: But later.
[SPEAKER_03]: You should be cataloging some chemicals.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me go get some chemicals.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know what it will do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you going to eat that?
[SPEAKER_02]: We're going to foil his stance.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, look.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm focusing on, like, the torture.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need you to be asking him questions.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why were you...
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you doing?
[SPEAKER_02]: What was the point of this?
[SPEAKER_02]: I should be very blunt about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that's why we do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: The point of what?
[SPEAKER_02]: Why assassinate the alchemist?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because he knows more than most.
[SPEAKER_01]: There were several reasons to kill him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's working on something that will counteract the effects of the Gift of Insanity.
[SPEAKER_01]: We couldn't let that happen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that that Black Plague shit that's happening out in the marshlands?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you've heard of the Gift.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I've heard of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mono would kill his dad.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, it causes insanity.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or complete clarity.
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the passage into consciousness.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm talking to you here.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Gift...
[SPEAKER_01]: Is a liquid from the dragon's self.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys are a little freaked out because this guy's eye is gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: His fangs are gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's bleeding down.
[SPEAKER_01]: He basically says, but also, we know what you're trying to do, Paul Ribeiro.
[SPEAKER_01]: Find a way to recreate the white powder that saves Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: We cannot allow that to happen.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the stuff that keeps...
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, what's the white powder?
[SPEAKER_01]: The yellow powder.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm sorry, the powder that... No, I actually intentionally played dumb.
[SPEAKER_03]: What powder?
[SPEAKER_01]: The powder Kane Toli has taken from the helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: We know you know about this.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that's why you wanted to take care of the alchemist.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because the alchemist not only knew how to stop the Samovar Plague.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's nothing that can stop the gifted Samovar Plague.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's nothing that can stop the gifted Samovar Plague.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's nothing that can do to shut off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul just fucking hates this.
[SPEAKER_01]: But definitely he can abrogate its effects on people.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was going into the war and
[SPEAKER_01]: Giving those affected by the gift some substance that helped take away their pain.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm done.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can drag them back, throw them in the cell.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can always take body parts off of them later.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is there anything you need to know?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because anything we need to say, I want to say not in their presence.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, okay, do you, yeah, please walk them up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, well, actually, how about this, how about this?
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll step out into the hallway a little bit, leave this guy in the chair, leave the guys guarding him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, no, no, we're not going to leave the dungeon yet, we're just going to go talk privately.
[SPEAKER_02]: Leslie, I don't think you'll want to do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: So come on, Leslie.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're coming with us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Leslie, you're coming with us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because actually, I do need Leslie.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need Leslie.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why do we need him?
[SPEAKER_03]: I need him for this next part of the conversation.
[SPEAKER_03]: But what I want to do...
[SPEAKER_03]: What I want to do is I want to make sure that we go not out of ear sight.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't want the female in that area.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just want to go out in the hallway.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to have a private conversation?
[SPEAKER_01]: Private conversation with these two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you guys move into another part of the jail to have a private conversation after that very disturbing torture scene.